one of the purpose-built coronavirus
hospitals in Wuhan will open its doors
on Monday another's due to go online in
the coming days together chinese
officials say more than 2,000 patients
with the virus will be able to get care
at the new facilities but with urgent
calls for more supplies and warnings of
understaffed and overworked medical
teams at the existing Wuhan hospitals
these new facilities will probably take
some time before they can run at full
capacity this as the announcement health
officials around the world have been
bracing for the first coronavirus death
outside of China a 44 year old Chinese
man from Wuhan died on Saturday in the
Philippines in his last few days the
patient was stable and showed signs of
improvement however the condition of the
patient deteriorated within the last 24
hours
resulting in his demise more countries
are flying their citizens out of Hebei
Province and New Zealand has joined the
list of Nations
barring non-citizens who have recently
traveled to China from entering as this
was supposed to be the end of the
extended Lunar New Year holiday the
streets of Beijing should be bustling
but the government here has said only
essential workers will return the others
not for another week at least businesses
and private enterprises are doing the
same many are stuck inside their homes
millions of Chinese are taken to social
media to talk about the coronavirus
mostly venting frustration on the slow
reaction of the Wuhan government when
the virus was first discovered and how
donations have been diverted or delayed
this story about a TV crew stopped from
reporting on the work of the Wuhan Red
Cross received nearly 300,000 comments
Chinese officials are also taken to
social media using it to notify the
public about details of cases of corona
virus so those who traveled on the same
flights trains or buses as infected
patients and were possibly exposed can
get tested to try and prevent the virus
from spreading further Scott hi there al
Jazeera Beijing